hey guys I'm Eric Voss and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 2 the well and after last week's
head splitting season premiere head
splittings not old worthy used to
describe things this episode was a total
change of pace catching up with Carol
and Morgan uh ignorance is bliss and
introducing us to King Ezekiel see not
all rulers a season are sadistic psychos
some are just loveable larper psychos
with Tigers and I gotta say even more
than last week this episode was packed
with hidden meaning and missable
references so much so that at times you
might had to like pause the DVR and be
like hold on okay let's keep going so
I'm going to try to translate and break
down all the stuff that I noticed about
interesting and as always duh come on
spoilers ahead if you haven't watched it
yet alright let's get started with the
opening images and it might have just
been me but these shots of Carol on the
cart looks super familiar that's because
they kind of directly echo the opening
shots of episode 15 last season so check
it out the first thing we see is this
carts wheel which reflects the flattened
tire back in episode 15 and Carol's
extra long sleeve that she sewed the gun
into and used to murder a bunch of
Savior's in that scene so what's the
point of all these connections I think
that that moment was an emotional rock
bottom for Carol it happened right after
she decided that she was too dangerous
to be part of a community and now we're
being reminded of that as Carol is being
brought into a new community and she'll
have to decide whether a life of safety
and comfort is something that she thinks
she deserves also check out how Morgan
is marking this tree with an X he tells
the others that he's marking his way
back but I don't think that's the only
reason I he's doing this so remember
back in season 5 Morgan tracked down
brick by following the exes carved into
trees left behind by the terminus people
by the way Sasha did the same thing last
season to help Daryl track down her and
Abraham uh it still hurts to say his
name so now I think Morgan could be
leaving a similar trail of breadcrumbs
for Rick to follow in case she goes down
to the kingdom because let's be honest
every time these people go somewhere
they ruin everything
and then notice this shot of Carol
looking up at the trees as they pass
overhead and the Sun shines through I
think this could be a reference to the
famous recurring shot in the movie
Rashomon director Akira Kurosawa used
the same upward shot of trees as a reset
for the film's framing narrative
structure revisiting one scene from
different
character's point of view as they recast
themselves in the light that best suits
their agendas and that idea of recasting
yourself creating a new identity to hide
behind will come back later this episode
okay and if you look closely you can see
this poor horse getting torn apart and
come on we got to admit this world sucks
if you're a horse pretty much every
horse we've seen on the show has died a
horrible death
Rick's horse back in the pilot episode
then there was Michonne horse back in
season 4 and then buttons oh sweet sweet
buttons that should have been new Aaron
and then now this horse and if any of
you were worried that The Walking Dead
has become too violent against people
horses have a way higher death rate okay
anyway I was really interested by these
shots of Carol hallucinating the walkers
as living people now to cool things
about these images first they imply that
Carol is still so traumatized by taking
lives that the distinction between
living Souls and reanimated corpses is
now blurred for her but another way to
read this is Carol is going back and
forth between one world the world of
living
and another the world of the dead and
I'll come back to this later okay moving
on to this shot of Morgan's lucky
rabbit's foot now we've seen that before
it belong the Eastman whose daughter
gave it to him to cheer him up and now
Morgan carries it as a token of that
world view that Eastman imparted onto
him that no matter how bad things get
the world hasn't ended and that faith in
humanity is something that Morgan has
been trying to pass on the Carol but
unfortunately no luck so far
rabbit's foot or no rabbit's foot then
we get this great look at the kingdom
and after the hilltop look so like
sparse and empty last season I was glad
to see the kingdom looks so legit and
full of life like they got plants
growing in file cabinets hipsters
selling that stuff on Etsy now the
kingdom in the comics is a former high
school not really sure what the history
of this kingdom is but in the video we
made for the trailer last summer we
pointed out how that in real life this
is Fort McPherson a former army base in
Georgia now repurposed as Tyler Perry
studios please God just once let us see
Ezekiel dressed up as Madea before we
get to the king check out this quote on
the wall hope is the North Star let it
guide you ke ke Kevin Eubanks look at
you spitting some philosophy in between
those Leno guitar riffs stupid tune okay
King Ezekiel's positive daily quotes
show up on the walls all over the
kingdom throughout this episode and to
be honest they're all pretty basic and
straightforward but what I find
interesting is the fact that they exist
all like this guy makes his people go
around reading quotes from himself
that's like walking into someone's home
and seeing this like massive portrait of
themselves on the wall it's weird
according to my ex also notice how this
passage is written in this old English
fantasy book font it's like these
passages are part of the fairy tale that
Ezekiel is telling people to make them
feel safe also it's important that the
first time we see Ezekiel he's sitting
on the stage in a theater on a prop
throne with the backdrop of the castle
now we know Ezekiel is all about touting
his stature playing up the theatrics of
his power lines it also foreshadows what
we'll learn about Ezekiel later that he
learned this act by working as a literal
community theater actor and Ezekiel's
introduction is just awesome the show
deserves some major props for
translating this character so well from
the comics to the show he's totally
over-the-top just like he is in the
comics but there's a method to his
madness that the show reveals later in
this episode so they don't lose us or
jump the shark which is really easy to
do with a pet tiger looking at you
Princess Jasmine Roger would have multi
did that years ago now the writer this
episode was mattnic Rhett who also wrote
the episodes that introduced us to
Abraham Eugene and Rosita and then more
recently the big negan season finale so
this guy knows how to give major
characters a big entrance
before I move on with the zekiel just a
few things I want to point out about the
opening credits a few new title slides
were added including this one for Josh
McDermitt
Eugene showing that the initials factory
that we saw in episode 14 last season
anyone who's read the comics knows why
this will become important Eugene's
character as we go forward but we also
get this new shop or Christian Serratos
Rosita and this grounded boat for a lot
of masterson Tara and also some comics
folks have been predicting that this
might be pointing towards another
community that the comics have really
only hinted at at this point so maybe
we'll see Tara Heath run into those
people this season or just a suggestion
maybe this boat could be the one that
Tara and Heath go out on into the ocean
and then it sinks and no one misses them
now getting back to this episode let's
talk about Sheba first off I just want
to say how relieved I am that the show
made Shiva an actual tiger as opposed to
like a pit bull or like a really hairy
dude with like face paint whiskers named
Shiva like ooh
sheiva he's just tackled us easy kills
Tiger is an essential component of his
character it's just the right amount of
what the [ __ ] and raw intimidation that
makes Ezekiel so great now Shiva was
actually brought to life through a mix
of animatronics and CGI Greg Nicotero
has been constructing animals with
practical effects dating back to the
late 80s and his team apparently started
building Shiva last February so kudos to
the show for keeping the tiger in the
bag for this long now this initial
dialogue between Carolyn Ezekiel is
fascinating because they're both
speaking in code pretending to be
someone that they're not so Ezekiel is
posing as this larger-than-life King and
Carol is posing as her sweet and
innocent alter-ego that she falls into
whenever she's new and wants to fly
under the radar like when she arrived in
Alexandria and when she got taken
hostage in episode 13 last season and
right before she shot up the Savior's in
episode 15 and seeing these two gifted
Impostors try to outwit each other
through meaningful gestures and loaded
statements is the closest The Walking
Dead gets to Game of Thrones and I mean
the layer dialog version the game of
Thrones not the super violent game of
throne you've gotta warn me on that come
on
anyway let's decode exactly what's going
on here so Ezekiel makes himself appear
more immense than he is peacocking Carol
plays right into it giggling like a
schoolgirl and calling Ezekiel amazing
deliberately mispronouncing Shiva as
Sheba and trying to make herself appears
smaller and less intimidating than she
is but Ezekiel as a fellow actor sees
right through this act and he uses this
bowl of fruit to test Carol this isn't
just grandstanding with a bounty of
tropical fruits
Ezekiel wants to know it's Carol really
is naive and is trusting and she's
pretending to be and then Carol shows
her hand by refusing the fruit but she
ends the greeting by flattering Ezekiel
nobody told me I'd be meeting royalty
ooh
so I know they're both in each other but
I'm sensing some sparks here now that
fruit has a ton of symbolist and I love
how it works into the episode so Ezekiel
mentions the pomegranate in particular
into the ancient Greeks the pomegranate
was a symbol of fertility and seduction
the fruit is actually considered a
natural aphrodisiac and no joke but I
think that this pomegranate becomes a
symbol for Carol and Ezekiel's
relationship this entire episode so like
in one Greek myth the god Hades
kidnapped Persephone and kept her with
him in the afterlife using a pomegranate
to seduce her now Hades isn't
necessarily evil he's just kind of a
weird loner
who
ruler of his own domain a lot like
Ezekiel and in this moment pomegranate
represents Ezekiel's desire for Carol to
stay but when Carol refuses a
pomegranate Ezekiel has this interesting
line sweet fruit surrounded by bitter
there's something of a contradiction but
heaven for the effort that contradiction
applies to Ezekiel and Carol as well
they're complex characters whose
external layers contradict their
internal natures Ezekiel loves that
contradiction Carol really can't handle
it but notice how he also says heaven
for the effort and it's fascinating that
the use of the word heaven here because
it connects this moment to another
ancient story that involves pomegranates
the Garden of Eden in the book of
Genesis that's where the serpent tempts
Eve into eating the forbidden fruit
promising her great wisdom and fun fact
in many interpretations of the Bible
that forbidden fruit in the Garden of
Eden wasn't an apple even though Ezekiel
has those two it's a pomegranate so by
offering Carol this forbidden fruit
Ezekiel is doing that same kind of
seduction recasting himself in this
exotic form hoping to get this woman to
join him in this heavenly Garden and
impart great wisdom to her but Carol's
like no thanks literally the most famous
Bible story told me to not take fruit
from strange men because to her Zico
seems like the total opposite from her
he's someone who lives in this fantasy
land whereas she lives in reality and
one more thing to talk about here
Ezekiel also brings up the title this
episode the well he says that in this
line which kind of becomes a major theme
in this episode drink from the well
replenish the world the well comes to
signify life comfort security goodness
nourishment all the good things that
Ezekiel in the kingdom represent to
Carol but Carol totally is itcool with
this drink / replenish arrangement
because in her eyes life is something
that she only knows how to take by you
know killing people that's the one major
contribution to a community that she
thinks she can make even all the bacon
she did for everyone in Alexandria last
season that wasn't her true self her
true self was Wolf Carol
whoof Carroll so just like Eid after she
got banished in the Garden of Eden Carol
still sees herself as too sinful to be
part of this life and goodness to drink
from the well moving on to this scene
with Morgan helping Ezekiel and the
others round up hogs a few things to
point out here one we've been seen
building the background of this episode
and a lot have you been wondering where
this takes place and we know we're
around Washington DC and the Crystal
City area outside DC has a few tall
corporate buildings like this but the
show still shoots in Georgia and the
cool thing here this shot is actually
the same establishing shot used back in
season two of real life downtown Atlanta
with that iconic Bank of America Plaza
building digitally removed also we get a
better look at Ezekiel skein which turns
out to be this awesome
Chico mazui that's a blade hidden within
a cane also the hilt has that same
design as in the comics and if you look
closely that's a Griffin this guy's like
really gone out of his way to peacock we
should talk about this weird speech and
he makes to the walkers
maybe one day see you all from this cos
he'll then know that we live on in your
place bull mastiff faithful and bring he
sounds like he says that every time he
goes out like that's Ezekiel's go-to
karaoke song and everyone's like again
seriously but this is also part of
Ezekiel keeping up this eccentric
narrative by talking to the walkers like
you can one day cure them he's reminding
us of that quote on the wall hope is a
North Star let it guide you he's like
really committed to being consistent
with these kind of budget philosophies
but I want to talk real quick about this
guy Richard he's clearly not thrilled
with this secret deal Ezekiel has with
these saviors to give them food and I
mentioned in the last video that if
[ __ ] didn't kill Abraham he would risk
having a defiant subordinate might
challenge the leader into fighting the
Savior's and right away we're seeing
that version of Abraham in the kingdom
with Richard in case it wasn't clear to
you Richard's plan here is to build
these pics with rotted Walker flesh
basically poisoning the Savior's with
Taha let's let Bob say it
that's gonna end well okay moving on to
this scene with Morgan and Ezekiel and
I'd like a Morgan refers to Eastman as a
cheese maker that's another callback to
Episode four last season when Eastman
kept that pet goat tabatha so he can
make cheese but then king and zekiel
hits us with more cryptic words with
this quote the pessimist looks down and
hits his head the optimist looks up and
loses his footing the realist looks
forward and the justice paths
accordingly now maybe it's just me but I
think that quote could be a meta
commentary for all the characters on the
show people like Rick Glen Abraham
they're all optimists who lost their
footing they spent all last season
making these big plans of the future and
then they paid this heavy price
meanwhile Carol is a pessimist with this
fatalistic view of the world which
hasn't served her well either meanwhile
Morgan has kind of been the most
pragmatic realist looking forward and
adjusting his path as he goes I also
like the double meaning of this line
whereas EQ acid Morgan sticks saved him
and Morgan smiles so not only has the
post have literally saved his life from
Walker's learning Aikido and embracing a
no killing philosophy has saved his mind
from self-destruction okay let's move on
to the kingdoms version of like vocal
adrenaline or the pentatonix or whatever
singing this acapella cover of Bob
Dylan's don't think twice it's all right
and okay I'm sorry but come on I think
he'll say that this place has a
guitarist whose talent brings tears to
the eye and sure a small choir but then
you get an acoustic Dylan song and you
go with the small choir like what the
hell is this like they might as well
just like panned over to actual Bob
Dylan being like oh you don't want to
hit for me hey but if you break down the
lyrics this song is actually perfect for
this moment it is kind of wasted my
precious time but don't think twice it's
all right speaker in the song is a guy
who really cares about someone but he
realized that she's not really
committing to him she's just wasting his
time so he kindly calls it quits this is
like the friendliest breakup song ever
and this exactly describes Morgan and
Carol's relationship this episode we're
gonna come to terms that Carol is just
not that into his philosophy and she has
to find her own path and I like how
specific verses sync up with shots like
today no you
I'm playing over Carol thinking hard
over whether or not to leave and then we
got you in
we go as Carol literally looks out the
window to see Morgan having moved on to
a hot new protege who's way more into
what he's preaching and during its
montage I love this shot of Carol
stealing the knife and hell why not the
Chocolate - that's a callback to early
in the episode when she joke said if
Ezekiel offered her chocolate it would
go bye-bye but also it's a callback to
last season when Carol got Sam to steal
chocolate bars for her from Olivia's
pantry so it's interesting that we're
seeing Carol go through these same exact
motions as when she was in Alexandria
she's fooling everyone with a sweet and
innocent routine while she quietly
gather supplies and specifically
chocolate and judging by the way that
she was looking at the wheelchair
earlier I don't think she needs it here
she just wants to look weak and
unassuming before I move on I just want
to point out this moment when Ben takes
a break from learning Aikido with Morgan
to talk about this philosophy book
instead the art of peace really this is
a student Morgan once someone who's
embracing the Zen worldview behind the
martial art not just the sick boo step
moves and wondering how is zekiel feels
about that because he just wanted Morgan
to teach Ben how to defend himself and
now he could be like I wanted this
weapon and you gave me a pacifist what
the hell but moving on to this reveal
that Ezekiel is in the same oppressive
relationship with the Savior's but he
has chosen hide it from his people and
this is interesting because it's not
really a secret in the comics so why do
they make this change now we find out
from Ben later that it's because Ezekiel
fears that if his people knew they'd
want to fight like Richard does and he
just wants to keep the peace which sets
up the possibility of some interesting
tension in the ranks if people ever find
out and playing along with the Savior's
also makes Ezekiel in many ways a wiser
more practical leader than Rick or he
could be a leader that has made those
same mistakes in the past but before I
get to that theory it's worth mentioning
this young savior Jared now Jared's a
dick he takes his cheap shot at Richard
after he's been ordered to stand down he
flicks them off he won't sit them as
they drive off now we've met a lot of
singers at this point and none of them
have really shown any virtuous qualities
there are the bikers on the road and
then Dwight the guy's the satellite
station Paula and her crew Simon and his
crew and then obviously negan and then
even this guy Gavin I mean he seems to
respect Ezekiel but he still it's Jared
getting a few hits anyway so none of the
Savior's we've seen have really done
anything brave or courageous or heroic
to make us think oh that's how they
survived for this long and I think the
show is painting the Savior
to be a group whose whole existence is
really based on their numbers and how
organized they are and the extremes are
willing to go to so really there's no
philosophy that makes them superior just
might makes right and I think that's
gonna end up being their downfall now
we're still getting to know these people
and the show may prove me wrong next
episode which looks like it's gonna tell
us more about Dwight he seems like he's
kind of on the fence like tried to run
from the Savior's but a dictabird arrow
like over and over again so I don't
really know about him but the rest of
them can go caught themselves okay gimme
Maggie that theory that I brought up a
second ago in this next scene Ben tells
Morgan about his father who died on a
supply run which led Ezekiel to be a lot
more cautious and protective of Ben now
that we know that Ezekiel is willing to
lie to maintain order I have a feeling
that Ben may not have the whole story
about his dad so here's the theory I
think Ben's father ran into negan and
thinking that he was invincible because
they had this God figure of Ezekiel and
a magical tiger on their side Ben's
father tried to fight me again but negan
did to Ben's father what he just did to
Glenn and Abraham because we know negan
has a policy to kill one person in every
new group that he meets and this Forrest
Ezekiel into this truce which he keeps a
secret because otherwise his facade is a
powerful King would kind of crumble and
the kingdom would collapse that would
further explain why Ezekiel is so intent
on training Ben and preparing him for
his council he feels guilty for sending
Ben's father to his death and he wants
to keep him close but if this is true
and if slash win this secret gets out it
would create some major tension between
Ben and Ezekiel and by the way fun fact
in the scene the actor who plays Henry
is Max and Lintz who is the brother to
Madison Lynch who played Sofia in the
first two seasons and if you look
closely behind Morgan here there's
another nugget of wisdom from our good
friend Kevin Eubanks the dead are alive
less not the alive be dead now that's a
super confusing statement just sounds
like something Ezekiel would yell at the
walkers like a madman the gender are
alive less not to the alive be dad the
walkers are just like tar what the hell
is that guy say I don't know
Dali's picked to stop baiting me so
here's the best translation that I can
come up with the dead are coming back to
life as brain-dead zombies and that's
awful so those who are still alive don't
die in fact I'm just gonna here we go
here we go there we go that's better
moving on this scene between Carolyn
Ezekiel in the garden is one of the best
parts of the episode it brings together
all these threads that I've been talking
about burst off
Carolyn Ezekiel finally cut the crap and
be honest with each other a total
reversal of that dishonest posturing
that they had in the earlier scene and
as I mentioned before hearing Ezekiel's
honest back story about how he was a
zookeeper in a community theater actor
who recast himself as this
larger-than-life King in order to build
a safe community for his people
it isn't just necessary for us to accept
and get behind this character it's
necessary for Carol to see that she
isn't alone in recasting herself in a
way that furthers her chances of
survival and now that she knows that
Ezekiel's masquerade is for a good
reason she can finally trust him and by
the way this whole monologue was Corey
Peyton's audition scene which he
obviously nailed and normally I'm not a
fan of these long speeches but damn I
could listen to Ezekiel or negan talk
for hours this conversation also ties in
those biblical and mythological
allusions so notice how this thing
begins with Ezekiel discovering Carol
stealing fruit in the garden which is
his favorite place in the kingdom
just like God catching Eve stealing the
fruit in the Garden of Eden which was
his utopia within his kingdom
so this recast Ezekiel from the evil
serpent to a good and benevolent God and
rather than casting Carol out which is
what she actually wants Ezekiel comes up
with another solution embrace the
contradictions so he's bringing back in
that symbolic pomegranate of taking the
bitter with the sweet and now that Carol
sees how Ezekiel can manage living under
false pretenses she is starting to see
how a self-contradictory life can work
for her too Ezekiel's proposal for her
to go but don't go actually connects
back to that Greek myth of Hades and
Persephone that I mentioned Persephone
was the only soul Hades allowed to pass
freely between the world of the living
and the world of the Dead and that's
what Ezekiel is allowing Carol here a
home on the outskirts of the kingdom but
not technically within the border of the
kingdom she's close enough to the well
but not in the garden with the will
remember those shots of Carol seeing the
walkers is both alive and dead I think
those shots were foreshadowing this
state of limbo going back and forth
between two worlds that Carol has now
chosen okay moving on to carolyn
Morgan's goodbye two quick things I want
to point out here one notice how Carol
says to him always watching always ready
that's a callback to the first
conversation and the four
I'm Carolyn Morgan met Morgan saw
through her sweet and innocent act and
asked if she used to be a cop will you a
cop too why would you think that we're
always watching you always uh Sheen
ready in a second thing notice how
Morgan lowers the flag on the mailbox
now that can mean several things since
this was one of Morgan's markers it
means Morgan doesn't need to return here
that his work is done with Carol but
also since this could have been one of
the bread crumbs Rick it also means that
he doesn't want Rick to be able to find
Carol and try to convince her to return
with him but addition to these I also
like the literalism of this image
Morgan is lowering a red flag as in
there's no reason for concern here Carol
is where she needs to be and wrapping up
with his final scene a few interesting
things happen here first
Carol builds a fire and assumes she's
alone but then a knock surprises her and
I think this could be a reference to
that famous short story knocked by
Frederick Brown it begins with this
famous two sentence passage the last man
on earth sat alone in a room there was a
knock at the door that line is
considered one of the best
self-contained super short stories that
create suspense and infinite
possibilities and which of those
infinite possibilities shows up at
Carol's door that's right a booty call
which leads me to the closing images
ezekiel and shiva show up with one of
these pomegranates the fruit that
represents love and light and
self-contradiction ideas that carol
until this point refused to embrace but
now check out that smile
she's totally ready to embrace those
things and yeah she's ready to go this
episode was titled the well referring to
Ezekiel's rule drink from the well
replenish the well which means in order
to receive life and love you have to
provide life in love and sure there's
going to be a lot of reciprocation going
on remember the opening images showed
Carol alone back at her lowest point
feeling lost and now she's home and
happy and letting someone into her life
and to borrow some word plate from Jerry
who's my new favorite character Carol is
finally doing well
okay I'm sorry let's get to some
lingering questions one what's gonna
happen with Carol and Morgan find out
about what happened to Glenn and Abraham
this is kind of crazy to see them go on
with their lives while chaos is
happening just like a few miles away so
will this spur either of them into
action which leads me to my next
question - would Carol and/or Morgan
draw the kingdom into a
war against the savior's by using
Ezekiel secrets against it so when you
think about it it was kind of foolish
for Ezekiel to trust these secrets about
his true backstory and this deal he has
with the Savior's two - relative
strangers when word getting out could
seriously destabilize his rule of the
kingdom and three what do you think
about this relationship between Carol
and Ezekiel Ezekiel actually hooks up
with a different member of Rick's crew
in the comics but I kind of like this
coupling a lot more considering how
kindred spirits these two are it's just
gonna be a little weird with Shiva
staring at them while they do it like
you know maybe leave her at home next
time you zekiel okay thanks for watching
and let me know what you think in the
comments and make sure to check out my
breakdown of last week's season premiere
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and share this video with all
your friends you can also contribute to
us on patreon and thanks so much to all
of our donors especially Kenny Smith
you're great thank you so much and for
the rest of you if you aren't currently
a patron we'd love your support you can
follow me on Twitter at leave us with
any theories or predictions or questions
that you had about the episode or you
can follow new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars to see when our videos
are coming out alright thanks for
watching bye